je suis d'accord avec la déprogrammation
oui oui je suis de réaliser ma dites
nous pourquoi parce que du point de vue
du téléspectateur
je pense qu'aujourd'hui quoi qu'on en
pense c'est impossible de regarder de
manière neutre
une oeuvre avec richard berry alors vous
allez me dire présomption d'innocence
il est même pas mis en examen les faits
seront sans doute mais prescrits je
comprends mais pour moi on ne peut plus
regarder sereinement donc quand on ne
peut plus être serein et bien il faut
surseoir il faut reporter je suis pas
souvent d'accord être france télévisions
mais pour moi ils ont pris la bonne
décision je vous le dis avec la
sincérité ya plein de gens qui sont pas
d'accord avec le so lu ment oui ou le
vous le savez alors géraldine maillet
pour moi c'est un scandale absolu de
démagogie et de justement de d'écouter
la justice médiatique en plus ses
téléspectateurs gines il est intelligent
s'il veut pas regardé le téléfilm la
nappe est et change de chaîne et il ne
regarde pas et boycottent la chaîne et
je trouve qu'aujourd'hui ben il n'est
pas encore accusé d' assurer qu il ya eu
une plainte ne lui incombe depuis qu'en
france télévisions est un tribunal à la
loi et à trélazé ski france télévisions
c'est un tribunal moral
vous savez ce que c'est sur france
télévisions je vous dire ce que c'est
l'adema de ça c'est la démagogie et
c'est quand on sait pas quand on sait
pas et quand on sait pas quelle décision
prendre 11 10 la décision la meilleure
c'est d'enlever directement le téléfilm
est elle une fois plus ça monte ça monte
le manque de courage
c'est un manque de courage énorme je
vous le dis on va voir la ville phare
zara
c'est plus un instant le 2 mètres
habitons également être femme est ok
mais c'est vrai que c'est bien le cas
pour revenir sur cette affaire vous qui
connaissez bien
richard berry vous étiez aussi vous avez
travaillé que jeanne manson longtemps
voilà qui s'accompagne on a eu vous
étiez son attaché de presse
vous étiez au courant de cet actif ces
accusations bah oui ça devienne publique
jamais jamais mais jamais j'en ai parlé
d éric jean ya pas très longtemps mais
elle tombe de sa chaise à chaque fois le
10 mai jamais ya eu le moindre le
lemoine c'est cette attitude absolument
de monstrueuses jamais elle a entendu
parler de ça mais sa fille shirel
d'ailleurs qui vivent en israël s'est
exprimé là-dessus a dit mais moi j'ai
fréquenté aussi colline lorsqu'elle
était petite
un week-end sur deux elle me dit jamais
on n'a entendu parler de ça et mes
parents enfin son père et sa belle-mère
bon jamais entendu parler de ça c'est à
dire que c'est très surprenant pour des
millions de français sont très très
surpris de la part d'un garçon comme
richard berry et jean mode swing se
récuser de ça mais moi ça me rase un mot
amène vers une histoire très importante
qu'on a oublié ici en france en 1985 il
ya une affaire aux états unis très
important d'une petite fille qui se
plaignait justement d'avoir vu ses
parents faire l'amour et que ça l'avait
complètement perturbé évidemment et puis
on s'est aperçu au bout de huit ans d'
enquête que la fille en fait avait
visionné tout simplement à l'époque une
vhs qui était resté dans le magnétoscope
de la chambre à coucher de ses parents
elle a 4 ou 6 ans l'avait observé ces
images évidemment qu'ils sont par son
âge et la fille avaient intégré dans son
cerveau qu'elle avait vu ses parents ont
fait faire l'amour et il a fallu
démontrer en attendant on a jeté l'eau
sale
évidemment sur les parents le surnom
huit ans il ya une procédure et on a
démonté un moment donné on a dit mais ça
vient de là l'histoire c'est à dire que
toute seule elle avait intégré la là
c'est une autre histoire
ça n'a rien à voir oui ces deux
histoires complètement différent je vous
dire on peut pas savoir ce qui s'est
passé
on attend comme france 3 ferme
laura pas faire comme france 3 faire un
tribunal ici aux épisodes passés
maintenant on attend que la justice
fasse son travail mais on sera prêt pour
le moment la question nature voilà
françois qui enlève richard berry at
elle bien fait des programmes et richard
berry oui moi j'étais sur un truc parce
que c'est annoncé quand même trois
semaines à l'avancé en dedans des
canards tonnes envoyées qu'à vélo volé
mon fils m'a dit non mais oui parce que
ce que je reproche le plus c 'est c'est
vrai que c'était difficile de le
maintenir mais ce que je leur reproche
le plus dans la déprogrammation c'est de
l'avoir fait en catimini quasiment sûre
façon honteuse mois qui suit les médias
je me suis rendu compte de la
déprogrammation en regardant le soir
même et en me disant tiens merde c'est
darroussin et non pas et non pas ceux
mairie donc ça veut dire qu'ils ont osé
s'opposer tout en osant dont c'était
particulièrement faux cul donc je
condamne d'autant plus la
déprogrammation alors s'il vous plaît
oui oui oui parce que c'était honteux cd
dire qu'il est honteux mais pour mes
vous l'auriez fait vous vous auriez des
programmes est bienvenu alors
personnellement tout et il y aurait fait
est exactement moi j'aurais des
problèmes pour deux raisons d'abord on
le conserve
on va nous reprocher d'être totalement
différent à la faire ça c'est sûr et on
l'enlève comme ils l'ont fait ils l'ont
fait sur leurs petits pas il joue une
raison de le faire discrètement
puisqu'en l'occurrence c'est ce qu'a dit
gilet jaune est montée cette semaine on
peut regarder et là comme ça
richard berry dans le rôle d'un avocat
défenseur chez seulement compliqué alors
vous êtes une chaîne
vous avez une ligne éditoriale répondre
aux crises ishaq un oui alors je suis
pas d'accord du tout sur les délais
alors alors france 3 qui décide qui est
coupable et qu'il n'est pas fendu rien
de quoi déplacer mais gilles a raison
quand vous regardez richard berry dans
un feuilleton comme ça comment vous le
regardez fabrice santoro qui regarde pas
du trône à mettre assez vite ce week end
avec nous avocats en droit des médias
est-ce que france 3 at elle le droit de
reprogrammer de tel de droit déjà
déprogrammée ce téléfilm ce qu'ils
avaient le droit alors ça se ressemble
fortement à une atteinte à la
présomption d'innocence les d'accord
mais ce qui est grave dans cette
déprogrammation sais que ça peut être
une incitation aux fausses accusations
rendez compte si on veut détruire
aujourd'hui la carrière de quelqu'un il
suffit de l'accusé la justice mettra
évidemment des années à enquêter et à
juger la faire mais en attendant
médiatiquement la personne aura déjà été
condamné elle aura subi des préjudices
lourd parce que ce que va entraîner
cette déprogrammation sur france 3 c'est
que des investisseurs pour des
productions à venir ne vont pas prendre
de risque des banques ne vont pas prêter
ils vont se dire je suis non c'est pas
possible ça peut être déprogrammée d'un
moment à l'autre
donc est ce que vous considérez que
france 3 a bafoué la présomption
d'innocence
oui oui on est d'accord oui ensuite
est-ce que contractuellement france 3
c'était protégés par des clauses
particulières dans le contrat avec
richard berry pour dire s'il se produit
certains fassent mais des accusations
d'avoir certains titres ça a été
effectivement il faut quand même
regarder ce que ce que prévoyait de
contrat mais effectivement on imagine
quand même que richard berry aurait une
action contre france 3 alors justement
vraie chance de gagner richard berry oui
alors vous savez je vais vous dire vous
avez dit tout à l'heure on sait pas on
n'a pas le dossier là de la même manière
effectivement je suis l'avocat ni de
france 3 ni deux donc mais a priori un
puisqu'on a priori effectivement cette
déprogrammation porte atteinte à sa
présomption d'innocence seulement il n'a
pas encore été jugé je pense qu'il
aurait quand même une action devant les
tribunaux sous pression mais j'aimerais
avoir l'avis d'un fatima benomar
militante féministe vous pour vous
fatima c'est une très bonne décision de
la part de france 3 juste un petit
détail la durée moyenne pour que les
enfants parlent de la question de
l'inceste et de la pédocriminalité ses
dix ans donc c'est normal qu'on
n'entende pas à parler dans les
premières années
ce sont des matières pour les avoir
suivies de près depuis très longtemps
très sensible les enfants c'est
compliqué de briser la curd le corps de
sa mère en disant en accusant son père
son beau-père et cgt passé dans plein de
médias ya trois ans suite à un homme qui
avait eu 18 mois de sursis pour avoir
violé sa fille de ces cinq à ses 12 ans
et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans la
justice parce que souvent on dit la
justice fera son affaire mais que nenni
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que le garde
des sceaux est en train de faire des
propositions parce que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans les tribunaux c'est
qu'on est en train de débattre sur le
consentement des gamines de 13 14 12 ans
parce qu on a l'une des lois les plus
mal foutu du monde m'a mentionné sur la
porte des programmations protège à
france 3 effectivement et les maîtresses
de seiche de ses choix éditoriaux et se
trouve dans une situation où elle avait
programmé un téléfilm
oui où on est dans des moments hyper
sensible juste après la prise de parole
de deux collines berry non son
communiqué ne l'accuse pas on n'est pas
en train de dire écoutez nous on a
décidé de croire colline berry et pour
cette raison des programmes et non pas
ce qu'il dit c'est que là tout de suite
façon j'aurais mal vu richard berry là
tout de suite faire la promotion du film
c'est que ce n'est pas le moment de vous
souhaiter manière et de toute manière la
passion la présomption d'innocence par
exemple olivier duhamel n'aura pas été
condamné encore et ben un moment il
n'est plus sur lci
c'est un choix raisonnable il fait par
la cei non non non oui la famille la
pratique mois s'est retiré lui même il a
dit voilà oui il n'a pas dit non je suis
je suis innocent si ce n'était pas tout
à fait pareil fatima mais je pense que
quand même la chaîne peut se dire
qu'elle n'a peut-être pas envie de
risquer de faire passer à téléfilm il ya
connu mme berry qui qui qui regarde et
il ya surtout c'est la deuxième fois que
je voudrais aborder un moment c'est un
peu triste à dire un peu violent à dire
mais c'est ce que j'essaye de pure
d'aider les années 20 alors que la
france se tiennent prêtes
pourquoi parce que la déferlante qu'on a
avec le hashtag mais tous inceste et
dans un contexte qu'on dénonce nous
depuis des années vous pouvez trouver
des vidéos de moins qu'il ya trois ans
quatre ans a dit oui à la bo référente
comme ça pour ça évidemment je le disais
je disais un jour on va
lever le tabou sur l'inceste et bien tu
avais des personnages importants qui est
emilien surya un enfant il ya un
français sur 10 qui concernées par la
perte de criminalité par la cei s'avérer
payant si elle a touché des gens
évidemment il ya 130 milles petite fille
et sans et 35000 petit garçon qui sont
concernées chaque année donc oui ça va
nous faire de la peine mais ça va
concerner beaucoup alors beaucoup
beaucoup d'anonymes nom les voix dans
les procès un peu anonyme consul jean
mais quand mais aussi des personnes
qu'on aime des personnes qu'on admire
des personnes qu'on qu'on adule et
jusqu'à présent il y avait un espèce de
déni français on disait ou bien c'était
les psychopathes des hommes pas éduqués
et tout pas du tout gabriel matzneff
salam qui peut être par ailleurs
brillant et cetera duhamel aussi la
deuxième chose c'était on a voulu donner
une couleur politique c'est à dire c'est
un truc post soixante huitard et tout
pas du tout il ya un élu du
rassemblement national qui vient d'être
mise en examen pour qui aurait violé sa
dauphine de 12 ans on a dit que c'était
une époque c'est pas vrai il faut
regarder ce débat dans les yeux encore
l'année dernière
les personnes qui soutenait polanski la
thèse c'était qu'à 13 ans elle était
consentante
c'est un homme de 42 ans et en 95 c'est
pas les années soixante mais soixante
dix il y avait au contraire ardisson et
beigbeder qui est en train de plaisanter
avec matzneff qu'ils auraient bien voulu
eux aussi finir la nuit dans un lit avec
des gamines de 12 ans annie c'est ça la
situation n'était pas aujourd'hui c'est
que le début je pense que ce n'est que
le début je pense que là ce qui doit
occuper nos débats c'est pas un téléfilm
qui est repoussé en mai c'est une
ascension à la jambe droite et m'a pas
ce que ça veut dire beaucoup de choses
oui ça veut dire que parfois il ya la
présomption d'innocence elle n'est pas
respectée sur les réseaux sociaux
elle n'est pas respectée non plus par
les chaleurs de télévision ça sur france
3 en faisant ça je vous dis france 3
faisant ça qu'on a vie à tous vos
téléspectateurs ici à la majorité des
français s'était envolé le faire richard
berry est coupable c'est parce qu'ils
disent dans leur communiqué
après justin cela que la terre de chasse
il voudrait dire un problème massif en
france c'est pas la présomption
d'innocence qui est piétinée c'est que
massivement et au plus haut niveau de
l'état on considère qu'il ya que 1% des
violeurs qui sont condamnés et qu'on a
une loi qui est mal foutue qu'on avait
on était le dernier pays en europe il
n'y avait pas de d'âge minimum
de consentement et que très franchement
cette affaire très souvent d'être classé
dépression on m'envoie me fallait que
d'un report de cette rediffusion du
téléfilm qui sera reprogrammée sur
france 3 et à une date ultérieure
marqueront vous tenez bon il a été
déprogrammé arrêtez moi je moi j'aime
les gens feront comme jean marie bigard
ah oui voilà oui mais ce avec quoi
j'aurais préféré que france 3 10 et
voilà maintenant eh ben oui on a on a
des programmes et ont fait pas là au
lieu d'adapter mais là ils sont entre
les deux
oui en fait un art ont poussé nos marais
pisé quoi ont des consignes
d'autres sources ont rapporté que c'est
de revenir à la raison
isabelle whisky ce qui me gêne dans ce
discours c'est que là aujourd'hui on est
en train de parler du cas d'un homme
richard berry et que pour justifier de
deux foulées au pied sa présomption
d'innocence
il nous parle de généralités sur
l'inceste la pédophilie etc et de cette
licence s'attendaient si vous avez si
vous connaissez le dossier parlez nous
en parce que moi le dossier
je ne le connais pas ce que je sais
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il n'a pas bradé
heures est-ce que j'ai des juges et non
ma chérie qu'ils ont réapparu et jugé
qu'elles ne pas le condamner et les
programmes et son téléfilm c'est le
condamner absolument pas s'il est si la
présomption d'innocence était fier de
signer ce matin on l'aurait emmené en
prison lui disant écoutez en france il
ya plus de présomption d'innocence on
vous a accusé vous vous retrouvez
médiatiquement à cause de nom de mercy
mais patrick bruel conseil vient chanter
normal
les traits sont celles de saison et vous
ne vais rien faire si votre combat est
noble a bien sûr dont il arrive assez
calme et attendre et surtout être
colossal sur tout le monde de cette
nature il faut avoir sagesse
imaginez-vous qui soit vous innocent
mais vous faites comment après pour le
réhabiliter vous venez vous êtes cynthia
2% 2 face aux fausses accusations nous
toujours le débat sur la présomption
d'innocence
moi en tout cas je l'avais en moi j'ai
le dis aujourd'hui en direct colline je
te croit et on est des milliards 3 rue
mais ça c'est mon avis alors devant les
sables et bâtiments en dix ans les
victimes de polanski qui soit condamné
ou pas on vous croit c'est pas grave et
il ya des milliers de personnes qui vous
regarde parce qu'en plus votre émission
est très regardée en moyenne il y en a
sur disque en train de se poser la
question est ce que je suis à la parole
et il faut le faire 26 ans et d'où nous
revoir je vous invite à chaque fois
qu'on doit débattre plainte dans cinq
dix pires si je parlais à quelqu'un qui
va me dire on en train de balancer sa
note senior non match et ma fille a
envie d'accuser son père fatima fille a
envie d'accuser son leur donnez moi
votre attributions ce point l'âge sur la
question des fausses accusations
je vous la corde c'est un phénomène
minoritaire
la plupart des femmes qui portent ces
accusations portent des accusations cl
on est bien d'accord
il ne faut pas en sont négligés s'il
vous plaît ce phénomène de fausse
accusation qui existe et qui est courant
qu'on rencontre plus souvent dans un
contexte de conflits familiaux notamment
dans des affaires de divorce ou la mère
veut récupérer les enfants connais juste
des faits
par ailleurs les procès jusqu'en elle
est très bien c'est genève c'est très
laid ni mizar d'ecombrement samedi
justement récup bâtiment ya aucune
excuse battus par lyon fatima mais ce
n'est pas une chaîne de télévision de
juger une arrière avant toute façon les
chambres il est déjà condamné par le
tribunal médiatique et populaire là il
en rajoute une couche
on veut faire du pardon mais c'est à la
tête du client parce qu'en 2018 ils
diffusent des films de woody allen qui a
aussi été pas bien sûr accusé de viol
par adèle haenel c'est parce que c'est
lui en soit la raison à des lettres et
lointain quand elle était jeune et ça va
se faire dans la douleur je le sais ça
fait des années qu'on ait su chasser en
et justine où on entend dans les procès
sur les gamines l allumer son beau père
parce qu'elles se baladent en culotte à
côté de lui et parce qu'il y avait des
conflits et blablabla on le sort qu'on
entend majoritairement dans les
processus père qui ne dirait pas le
contraire m c'est sur ces matières la
sacem c'est peut pas laisser comme ça
que ça se passe je suis maman qui nous
parle d'un flot de l'inceste écoutant
leurs paroles ne commençons pas à faire
tout en un tour de parole pour dire oui
mais peut-être qu'elle ment machin ou
peut-être qu'elle dit la vérité et pour
l'instant richard berry de toute façon
c'est prescrit donc le débat politique
composent ces deux là hélas hélas
médiatiquement ils sont en train de nous
tuer mais la plainte n'aboutira pas de
toute façon et encore moins y aura
enquête effectivement et c'est un
classement sans suite mais c'est une
dérive en général il ya des plaintes
après y porter plainte dans la glace je
vous dire ici on est pas les avocats de
richard berry mais pas du tout mais bon
voilà c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas du tout
les avocats de richard berry on est
juste voilà et je vous le dis fatima
c'est que voilà moi quand on polanski
était aux césar on a été les premiers
d'ailleurs c'est le même bruit que nous
on a été les premiers à dire que c'était
inadmissible et moi des lunettes judo
neuf cent fois raison
voilà d'adeptes peut-être partie des
césar je pense qu'elle a très bien fait
mais elle a pris la bonne décision
aujourd'hui ce qui nous on attend on
attend que la justice soupçonne avocats
de la présence
mais qui ne le fait pas j'aurais l'adoré
c'est le seul ministère la justice qui a
comme nom une vertu la justice
effectivement envie de croire en la
justice de son pays
je peux vous assurer que je suis entré
dans le militantisme en 2009
chaque fois que j'y crois quand je vais
en procès je me dis moi si ça va bien se
passer
c'est ce pas si cette fois ci c'est
après midi mais c'est pas vrai et
jusqu'à il ya quelques ya quelques
semaines le garde des sceaux nous
faisait mentir sur notre propre chiffre
maintenant il les reconnaît
reconnaissons-le expertise de militantes
féministes qui ne sommes pas sur des
positions idéologiques mais qui avant
une expertise de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui le viol la pédocriminalité
et les uns c'est ce sont des crimes
massivement puni en france et la vérité
on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs cassard est intéressant
aussi de la wii à 26%
non là 74% sur 74% soit là arnaud
lemaire sa directrice et fiction a
reconnu a dit ce soir que les protéger
elle a fait ça pour protéger pour
l'acteur
merci c'est bon tant de conneries
pareilles